salut les amis ce qu'elle girac pour
brut
[Musique]
mon père savait jouer de la guitare sauf
que moi je savais chanter mais je ne
savais pas jouer à la guitare et je la
voyais tout le temps sauf que je savais
pas m'en servir ça me tenait à coeur
d'apprendre d'apprendre cette guitare
donc un jour j'avais j'ai attendu
jusqu'à l'âge de 13 ans et je me suis
dit il faut que j'apprenne maintenant
voilà comment j'ai commencé à apprendre
la guitare de mon père je lui ai demandé
papa est ce que tu veux apprendre jouer
à la guitare il n'a pas voulu me dit non
je peux pas te prendre parce que moi je
me suis appris tout seul donc tu fera
pareil ça m'a un peu bloqué mais moi
j'avais pas le personnel s'était pas un
gars à me dire à chaque fois tu joues
bien bravo me disent à chaque fois que
il manquait quelque chose il disait
jamais bravo facilement et il ya pas si
longtemps j'ai eu un petit bravo quand
même de mon père ça m'a fait énormément
plaisir c'était dans la période du
confinement m'a dit maintenant tu joues
bien ficelé et là ça m'a fait énormément
plaisir parce qu'il ça faisait longtemps
que j'attendais ce petit ces petits mots
du pape
[Musique]
j'ai chanté à l'olympia je me souviens
c'est un souvenir incroyable parce que
c'était aussi mes débuts c'était mon
tout premier olympia
j'ai pu amener mon père sur la scène de
l'olympia c'est très important de
pouvoir partager ce moment là avec mon
père parce que vu que c'est lui qui m'a
appris la musique maintenant c'est un
manteau à moi de lui faire un petit
cadeau et de l'amener sur scène avec moi
pour passer un vrai moment sur scène
voilà pour partager nos talents qu'on
avait depuis tout petit en fait où on a
grandi avec et je trouve que c était
très important de partager ça avec mon
père mais une petite anecdote avant de
monter sur scène à chaque fois je disais
papa j'ai peur je stresse et il venait
vers moi il me disait mais arrête tu as
peur de quoi tu pourquoi tu stresses
sans rien disait chanter puis c'est tout
et moi je disais un jour tu verras j'te
ferai monter sur scène et là tu vas
comprendre pourquoi tu va stresser et ce
jour là où on a chanté à l'olympia sur
la scène quand il est venu je les vois
ça marche qu'il était stressé il
arrivait pas à chanter normalement et je
me souviens il avait il avait chanté
avec son micro mais l'avait resté figé
face à moi alors qu'ils avaient le
public
donc je savais pas comment faire pour le
tourner pour lui dire que paris le
public là tu vas après le concert
j'étais le voir dans la gelée déjà l'or
mais ça stresse ou pas il m'a fait il
dit ça stresse trop et qui voit là
cette année-là en 2015 mais c'était pour
les nrj music awards
j'avais j'avais gagné ce soir
l'anniversaire de mon grand-père et
après le sort que j'ai gagné la fa lui
que je dise un petit mot et est là
j'avais fait un coucou à mon grand père
sur la scène et quand j'ai voulu parler
de lui mais ma gorge serrée et je me
suis pas empêché de vider quelques
larmes ça me faisait du bien parce que
c'était pour moi c'était que je
reconnaisse un peu ce que mon grand père
m'a laissé le talent qui nous a laissés
à nous parce qu'il n'ya pas que moi qui
joue j'ai dans ma famille j'ai aussi mes
petits cousins qui chante c'est qu'il
joue de la guitare
donc voilà je voulais un peu relevé et
remercier mon grand-père qui qui qui qui
nous a donné tout ce talent en fait
c'était sa mue en que ça l'est mais
encore là est du coup elle c'était un
moment vraiment très très très fort à
vivre et à mon grand père oui il m'a
laissé il m'a laissé un héritage un
héritage musical de talent en fait de
chant et de guitare presse quand je le
voyais jouer à la guitare j'ai essayé de
faire comme lui même sauf que lui quand
il prenait la guitare on aurait dit
qu'il en avait trois et j'ai jamais
réussi à faire comme lui et quand
j'avais pris la guitare pour essayer de
lui jouer un morceau
j'avais fait à peu près pareil mais mais
chez nous les vieux c'était tellement
bref elysées c'est pas comme ça petit tu
ferais n'importe quoi là il m'a repris
la guitare et me faisait une leçon genre
il le centre mais je suis papou je peux
pas faire ça moi c'est lui qui a
influencé toute la famille et tous les
petits enfants et même ses enfants ont
repris
on a repris toutes ses chansons qu'ils
savaient faire et donc c'est grâce à lui
qu'on a l'amour de la musique
aujourd'hui
donc voila merci pour cet héritage